it's nearing two months since apple
released the max studio and we wanted to
give you an updated list of the top
issues that plague this machine for
those of you guys that have bought one
to watch out for and those that want to
get one to make sure you know what you
are getting and we have gotten some new
issues as people have used them and as
we have tested them now i'm also going
to cover the studio display that we
absolutely love just like the mac studio
that one is great but we wish some
things were different now let's go ahead
and jump right into it now the first one
is the coil whine or high pitch noise
issue now personally we have gotten
lucky with this but a lot of people have
been talking about it talking about our
comments on forums with this is where
you have this high-pitched quiet but
annoying sound that's in the background
now this was very prevalent in a lot of
dell xps laptops some graphics cards but
this in fact is not coil wine in the mac
studio it is actually the fans there are
dual fans with both of the mac studios
the m1 max and m1 ultra and they run all
the time even though the systems are
extremely cool running they're running
about 300 rpms now it seems like some of
these are having a high pitch sound or
whine now some people have actually
gotten around this by using some fan
control software like tg fan pro which
i'll link down in the video description
to lower the rpm down to about 1100 and
that makes it a lot better or ramp it up
slightly if you want to now these
machines should be completely silent 99
of the time they are amazing now in
reality what you could do is you could
get it swapped out for another
machine but i'll talk about that in just
a bit now the second issue is the system
not booting up or crashing now we
actually had this happen to ourselves
probably about two three days after we
got the base model it would not boot and
we would just get a sos flashing light
now it was working just fine it was
connected and all of a sudden it crashed
and wouldn't turn on now some people are
actually getting this when they just
open it up out of the box and they're
trying to set it up and it won't turn on
it's a software issue i think it's with
the older version as a mac os so you
can't actually fix this if you have a
mac running the latest software using
apple's configurator tool that will
revive your mac so it's not too terribly
hard to do you can just follow all the
steps but it does take some time and it
is annoying now the next thing is just
the fact that these aren't available
because i tell most of you guys don't
deal with the fan issue don't have to
fix it if that comes up just go get it
swapped out but in many cases these are
sold out until july or even up to three
months if you go in and do a custom
order that just shows how popular these
are and of course there's chip shortages
and things like that so if i had these
issues i would try to work with it for
now and then if you have a fan issue
well just wait and then when they come
in stock then reach out to apple and say
hey we're having this issue can you guys
please fix it or get me a new one and i
know they've done that in the past with
previous macs now the next issue are the
quad encoders in the m1 ultra now we
wanted to wait a bit before we talk
about this for us to get software
updates and then we did we got the
latest version of final cut the apple
finally released took him forever
davinci resolved they released version
18 premiere was updated and this is
still an issue now we personally got the
ultra as our main video editing machine
because we want super fast export times
but unfortunately when you look at these
charts the export times are the same if
you're looking at final cut in davinci
resolve and also premiere pro there's a
slight slight difference but it should
be twice as fast or at least close now
we have some insider information that
basically told us
yes technically apple is right what they
announced on stage they do have quad
encoders but those quad encoders can't
really do anything because the
limitations are the codex and the way
the software works and the way that mac
os is written future versions of mac os
will get better and we'll have some
improvements but that's going to be at
least half a year away and then even
still it won't be twice as fast it'll be
some small improvements so they were
right they're quantum coders but if
you're buying this higher end model like
we did just to export videos faster well
you guys see a lot of times the speeds
are identical even if you spend twice as
much or more now the next one ties into
this and that's software optimization
we've been talking about this ever since
the m1 chips came out a year and a half
ago and some things were working pretty
well but we now know that this is a much
bigger deeper issue apple released their
latest version of final cut and almost
nothing changed and in fact final cut is
being beaten out by davinci resolve
which is crazy now that we have these
high performing chips those software
optimizations or lack thereof they're a
lot more noticeable and if apple is
struggling with it well that says a lot
and with this the m1 ultra itself
is showing us a lot of issues on the
graphics side on the cpu side it's a lot
easier we're getting some nice gains in
lightroom in logic that's the same thing
where the m1 performed really well and
stuff got optimized quick for cpu but
with these higher cores with these ultra
chips we're seeing that in many cases
the 64 core isn't much faster than the
48 and with that the 48 is not twice as
fast as the 24 like it should be we've
had numerous software engineers tell us
that optimizing for arm from intel x86
is a piece of cake compared to doing the
necessary optimizations to get the m1
ultra to work at its proper capacity now
davinci resolve has done a killer job
they were actually the first ones even
beating apple to have support for pro
res raw decoding with the afterburner
you see their encoding speeds for
regular video they're much faster than
final cut latest version and even they
are not fully optimized yet and the way
we know this is because the graphics is
actually underclocking itself because
we're not getting data the proper weight
and there's a big bottleneck and
basically we just have a funnel where
it's going through this little you know
small bottleneck of bandwidth and then
the graphics card is slowing down using
not a lot of wattage which we've shown
you guys now the latest version of
davinci resolve the 64 core model will
actually run at about 1100 megahertz
instead of the proper 1300 but final cut
on the other hand still runs at about
752
showing that even apple can't optimize
for these high-end gpus and we've seen
with xcode's tool that's for like
blender for example half the time it's
sitting there and the graphics card is
not doing work
even though it shows us that it's a 100
usage so there's so much extra
processing and things that need to get
done to fix this and it's going to take
a lot of time
in apple for their later chips their
newer updated ones they're actually
changing the way they're making this so
that you don't have to be as optimized
so you can get better performance on the
hardware level just because of how
difficult it is to make these changes
and optimize for apple's high-end
graphics chips it is because of this
that we are actually going to stick to
the m1 max even though it's not
perfectly optimized yet the balance is
really good and because the quad
encoders can't be used it's not a big
deal for us and the machine is
incredibly fast check out our full
review if you guys want to get more info
now let's go ahead and shift to the
studio display this thing is expensive
but the quality is top-notch the
speakers are amazing the mic is amazing
but i have a couple issues with it not
including the price tag
the first thing is the webcam apple said
that there was a software bug that was
making the webcam look absolutely
terrible but they just released an
update we tested it out and yes it is
better in some ways but not in always
now the framing they actually put effort
into making it work properly instead of
having way too much headroom but there's
now way too much contrast and the actual
detail went down because they're adding
extra contrast and a lot of extra
de-noising now what really blew my mind
is when i compared it to my iphone 13
pro using the standard camera using the
camo app which also linked below the
quality difference is absolutely insane
now i know what you guys are gonna think
hey this is an iphone camera you know
it's way more expensive than apple's
ultra wide center stage that digitally
crops in which is why it looks so bad
well apple now they're selling the
camera module for 111 dollars and then
giving you a chunk of money back when
you send back the original and that rate
is actually flat rate even for like an
iphone se they'll charge you that and
then give you a lot of the money back
when you send it so there's definitely
enough room we only need one good camera
it's running the same software so it
could use it why would apple just not
put in a normal camera that looks great
instead of having that cropping ability
which how many people need that in a
desktop display
and having this quality issue so it
definitely is a bummer and it definitely
is not only software and if you don't
believe me that it is the hardware check
out this comparison with the imac pro
from 2017
look at that quality difference the
software fixed studio display from 2022
and that imac pro from 2017 it is just
crazy now that leads me into my last one
and this is something that i would
absolutely love i know apple won't do it
but to allow this expensive display to
have more capabilities i would have
loved to be able to even run a web
browser or ios apps on it because it
actually has a full iphone 11 not even
the iphone sc because at 64 gigs of
storage and four gigs of ram built-in
running the latest ios
but it's not doing anything with it and
previously you can buy an imac for 1800
bucks often 1600 on sale that's a full
computer built in with a 5k display so
if apple would have allowed you to run
at least ios apps or ipad apps on it
without a display plugged in that would
make it such a better value proposition
and make it such an awesome tool for
people that want to have a display set
up like an imac at your desk so you can
do basic web browsing tasks which people
spend most of their time on and then
plug in a laptop or whatever else for
heavy tasks that have been amazing just
like the samsung m8 that we recently
showed off so the hardware is built in
the software's there but apple's not
doing anything with it including having
a pretty terrible webcam also which is
crazy so that would have just been
amazing but of course they don't want to
do that because i'd be too good of a
value so there you guys go we really
like the studio display the quality the
mac studio also is amazing especially
the base model for the value that you
get i would say
still pick one up if you enjoy it um if
you're if it's gonna do a good job for
you consider buying a macbook instead
maybe if you're buying a base model i
have a full video on that over there
with a lot of reasons why that might be
a better value click above to subscribe
if you guys want to see more videos it's
been max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]